by government in terms of handling
corporate relations
and i just would say that we have
listened to the treasury select
committee's
earlier hearing and so mr cameron won't
need to answer
any of those points and can refer to
those former
answers where that's appropriate that we
may still probe and also to flag that
our sister committee
the uh constitutional affairs committee
um public administration and
constitutional affairs committee to give
it its full title
is also conducting a wider inquiry about
the issue of lobbying so that is also
not
really our main focus today um so mr
cameron we're hoping we can
dispatch this within an hour or so with
your support
in in swift answers where that's
appropriate um and
uh we i will hurry things along as
necessary but we do need the time
to ask the questions and you need to
have the time to answer them so we do
appreciate
uh that that might not quite run exactly
to timetable
so without further ado i'm going to pass
to the deputy chair of the committee sir
jeffrey clifton brown
to kick off over to you sir jeffrey
thank you chair good afternoon david
um you've had a long session with the
treasury so we're going to keep this
finished short and brief
when in your time in office when did you
first become aware of the possible use
of supply finance uh two in the public
sector
well um lex greenseal was employed
by i think jeremy haywood was
responsible for bringing him into
government i think in 2011
i don't think i met him till 2012
by which time he had worked up one
initiative which was two things it was a
mixture of
private sector companies that were going
to use supply chain finance
to ease credit conditions for their
suppliers to help with the credit crunch
which i was all in favor of
and there was this one government scheme
to
enable nhs pharmacies to be paid more
quickly by
under supply chain finance rather than
by the nhs so
i announced that package in october 2012
i don't think i had any other engagement
with the issue while i was in office but
my understanding is that other such
schemes and ideas were looked at but
none came to
fruition so i had a relatively limited
experience with it but in terms of the
one issue that came forward i think it
was
some i would describe it as beneficial
but but but lex hill
lex greenshield didn't suddenly arrive
in number 10
somebody must have briefed you at some
stage on supply
finance who was that and when was it
well i i just i would suspect it would
be jeremy hayward and i would have been
informed at some stage that this
appointment was being
made i don't think i played any part in
the run-up to the appointment but all
the
as i understand the cabinet office
papers are being looked at
and the nigel bourbon inquiry will be
looking at this but i'm sure i would
have been informed
um that he was coming in to look at this
issue
and as i say then my interaction with
him was really around 2012.
so you were asked in the treasury select
committee
what its use was what what's advantage
was it in the public sector given that
there is
a public contract regulations and given
that government on a departmental basis
pays most of its bills in the high 90
90s in 30 days and
the high 70s in five days what is the
necessity or what is the advantage
of supply chain finance in the public
sector
i think there are um two or three
important points to make about why it
has an application and i think the nhs
pharmacy scheme is a
is a good example and you would have
heard of the treasury
select committee figures being quoted
for it saving the nhs 100 million pounds
a year
because they're not having to reimburse
the cost of capital of nhs pharmacies
and also pharmacies themselves saying
how much they like
having the early cash because it eased
their cash flow meant that they weren't
having to borrow so much from
from banks so i would say in looking at
the public sector a couple of points
the first thing is although public
bodies
say they want to pay their bills early
and huge progress has been made and a
lot of credit needs to go to those
organizations
there is in some public bodies just a
level
of bureaucracy and paperwork that's
involved in
generating invoices and paying bills
that means there is a delay
and the nhs would be a good example of
that and so
using an outside provider who can
pay the pharmacies or other small
businesses immediately
and then reclaim the money from the
government
there's an advantage in doing that
because instead of being five days it
can be effectively
one day that's point one second point is
you can use as we did with nhs
pharmacies
actually go one better than um paying as
soon as an invoice
is generated you can predict what nhs
pharmacies are going to be prescribing
and pay them in advance and that's
what's happened with the nhs pharmacy
scheme so that's
point number two point number three is i
think
complicated but important in his
evidence to the treasury select
committee
nick mcpherson said yes of course the
treasury is in favor of early payment
but do remember that
early payment does mean the treasury
having to
produce more cash borrow more money and
therefore pay an interest charge on it
so there's a cost to the treasury
and i think the point that um mr
greensell made in the
committee which i'd repeat is of course
if you use an outside
supplier of that finance and you pay
your suppliers early
remember you're paying them early but
with a discount
they are effectively paying for that
early payment
rather than the treasury so i think
those three reasons are good
reasons for considering that this is not
some sort of
um bizarre uh idea
but actually has a real world
application so if it's so desirable
why did any one major scheme get off the
ground in your time
that is a very good question and i don't
know the answer to it
i think it'd be necessary to ask
either mr greensell who was working in
the government at the time or perhaps
some of the cabinet office
folk who were working with jeremy
hayward
um very sad is no longer with us i think
lots of other applications were
looked at um but the the nhs pharmacy
one was a sort of
you know a really straightforward
straightforward but a really
good one because the benefit was going
to these effectively small businesses
um but i i can't really answer that
question isn't the real answer
that the treasury were always
pessimistic even
opposed to supply chain finance for the
very reasons that you've already laid
out
that they've got to pay out the money
and pay the interest
well i think they no well of course if
you're using supply chain finance
the treasury aren't paying out the money
that's the whole point
when you use supply chain finance so for
instance at the moment
the nhs pharmacies are being paid by
what it was the case before the company
went under they were being paid
immediately by green sill and the
government the nhs was paying green seal
back
after 30 or 60 days so it wasn't
treasury money i think that reluctance
in the treasury sort of relates to two
points
which are both important points one is
as nick mcpherson said if you do pay
very early
um that means you're borrowing more
money and paying an interest charge on
it that's the government paying early
i think that's the first point and the
second point is they are i think
um nervous about using an outside
supplier because of course the
government's cost of money is lower than
anybody else's exactly
but of course the government's cost of
money is not always transferred from the
treasury to
individual departments individual
departments cost of money
is a weighted cost rather than
necessarily the government cost so
i i think there is merit in looking at
these schemes they're not i mean some
people have said
it's all totally pointless i don't
accept that you know i would say listen
to what the pharmacists say they they've
enjoyed this scheme and had merit from
it
thank you very much um barry gardner mp
thank you chair um when you were prime
minister
mr cameron lex greensell had access to
you as an unpaid advisor
can you just set up how that came about
because apparently there's no
documentation of israel at number 10 and
the public might think it
incredible that a guy can have a desk in
the cabinet office with no salary
and yet be off the official register
radar
i assume he must have had a pass and
security clearance
how did it all come about well my
understanding
um is that mr greensell
was brought in by jeremy hayward who'd
known him from a previous
job jeremy i think had all great
intentions and his outstanding sermon
he was conscious of the fact that the
civil service can benefit from outside
advice and neighborhood
and my understanding is he brought it in
with this remiss of looking at
how government can do better paying
bills faster particularly small
businesses
and whether there was an application for
this uh approach
and he had an office in the cabinet
office i i'm sure i was informed he was
coming and
would have said yes let's have outside
experts but i
i haven't yet seen a paper trouble um
for that for my understanding he was
a given office given the pass brought in
by jeremy
and would have been reporting in some
way through the
cabinet well as you said to the treasury
select committee and
so generally a an amazingly fine civil
servant
is no longer here to explain and defend
himself but
um when mr greensell accompanied you
to a federation small business
conference you gave him what i think is
known as a shout out
saying lex where are you give us a wave
and you told the audience lex is sorting
out the whole supply chain
issue for us so you clearly knew him
quite well by that stage that's 2014
three years on
but you'll recall liam fox's resignation
letter to you
over his unpaid friend and adviser
adam werty in that letter he said that
he had mistakenly allowed his personal
and professional responsibilities to
become blurred
do you think that perhaps the same
happened with you and lex queensland
no not at all because my recollection is
that between 2011 when let green sale
arrived in government
and between the time i stopped being
prime minister
i'm pretty certain i met him no more
than twice and i think the two times
were when we met to discuss
um the announcement in october 2012 of
the initiative that i just
spoke to sir jeffrey clifton brown and i
think the second meeting was when we
went to this
federation of small business speech
i remember thinking that the supply
chain finance initiative
was a good one and i remember the event
in downing street where there were
lots of uk corporates who had agreed
to use this approach and i liked it
because we were in a credit crunch at
the time the bank weren't lending in a
way that we wanted them to
and this was a way of extending credit
to small businesses because effectively
they were using
um if it was vodafone and they were
using vodafone's
ability to borrow money to borrow money
themselves to put it
simply so i think the shout out if
indeed there was one and i've been told
about it so it must be true
the shout out was because i thought this
was a good initiative and i remembered
announcing it but i don't think
otherwise i had any interaction with lex
greenshield
um at all so that was just your
natural bonner in in a crowd well i i
like to think
so but i don't actually recall it but
i've been told about it so i'm sure it's
true
okay thank you thank you very much mr
gardner
uh uh mr peter grant i hope you
thank you jeff good afternoon mr cameron
can i move on to your decision a few
years after you that left office
to go and work with green cell capital
what was it that attacked you to work
for them
rather than presumably one of a number
of
organizations that might be quite keen
to recruit you
um when i um met up with
mr greensell after i left office
and he told me about the business that
he had created and was growing
and i was looking at a number of as i
said
in the treasury select committee i had
some pro bono charitable work with
alzheimer's and dementia and fragile
states i wanted to
do some business interests as well
i took quite a long time to make up my
mind but
what i thought was interesting about
green sill
was this core product of going to
big businesses and saying let us pay
your supply chains
immediately and then you pay us after 60
or 90
days and in the meantime we raise the
money on the capital markets
what i liked about that was it was
helping small businesses with cash flow
which is a key concern
so to me it was like many of these
things that are happening in our economy
taking
one thing that the banks have done and
not always done very well
and trying to make it better cheaper
faster
digital paperless and all the rest of it
so it was if you like a sort of
um a uk fintech potential success story
that is what i thought was
interesting um i thought about it very
hard before
joining um i did some due diligence i
explained to the treasury select
committee but obviously i'm very sad
this
you know company ultimately failed but
that was
what i was thinking i i was interested
in
as prime minister i tried to promote
fintech and make sure we were a fintech
leader he was a fintech
success story and i thought it'd be
interesting to get involved
was your decision influenced to any
significant extent by
dealings that the government had had
with domestically so
previously that was entirely the
conversations that you had
after kids left office that would made
up your mind
really good question just to be
absolutely clear there was no
conversation while i was in office
with mr greensteal about potentially
working for him as i said that i've met
him twice and that was never
raised with me when he did come to see
me after i left office and talked about
his business and then
talked about me potentially being an
advisor
the fact that i had um you know
announced something in government and
had taken up this technology and and
pushed for it that did
uh have a bearing on on my understanding
of what he was trying to do it meant
that i wasn't coming to this whole idea
cold um and uh
you know so that was a point of shared
interest if you like he said
you seem to warn to and understand what
this industry is about when you were
prime minister
and of course i had the recollection of
the announcement we made and what i
thought had been a positive
effect but there was no other connection
as it were between the two
events thank you and looking at it from
the other side apart from the fact that
you were a recent former prime minister
what do you think they saw in you the
media better pick than
another other people who could have
approached um
well that's really a question for them
rather than me i think that
as a company that was small but growing
that was competing with big banks
that wanted to expand internationally
that wanted to win over
new clients i think that was the
attraction was having someone who would
run up their sleeves and
help expansion in china or india help
win clients in australia or america it
was very much about that
the public sector side of the work um
was very much later when i joined it was
really
focused on winning these big corporate
customers and i think they thought i
would bring
some uh enthusiasm and ability to that
but it'd be better to ask him really
thank you in your evidence earlier to
graduate select committee and you said
that you were
employed as a lobbyist you employed in a
different role
while being so um but at some point
you effectively became a lobbyist they
can have sanitations directly
to uk government ministers and others
who was initiated the process for which
she became a lobbyist
within the uk system as opposed to the
role that eventually
you know i think there were there were
two developments the first was
the potential economic
crisis following from kovy where
suddenly the issue of how
lending and credit could be supported
became a very live issue
and an important issue for greensville
because we were
funding a lot of companies supply chains
i can't remember exactly how the
conversation came about
but um it was i think really that
saw the bank of england talk about
helping to finance supply chains we saw
this scheme the
ccff come about and green still thought
well we have a great idea for improving
it
and so the need was to try and get that
in front of government and i think
that's where i became involved the
second development was
um it was
in thinking about how to pay
suppliers early and why it was a good
thing
it was an obvious leap to say well the
most important
supplier for any business is the
workforce and if you can use
technology through companies
erp systems to pay their supplies why
can't use the same technology
to enable um workers for that company to
draw down their salary as they earn it
rather than wait till the end of the
month
and i thought that was a fantastically
exciting development
and green sill decided that
you know in the nhs for instance and in
the public sector
this should be done for free for free to
employer and employee
why that was so important is you know
any of these schemes that allow salary
advance
to companies if you charge the employee
even a small amount it's still a big apr
it's still a big interest charge so this
was always free to the employee which
attracted me a lot
for free to the employer as well i
thought it was a tremendous
give back to the nhs and public sector
workers and i was very keen to
talk about that and so there's no secret
about that i became a
of you know a big explainer and
um a big enthusiast for him
thank you mr cameron you'll be assumed
that this experience didn't actually
answer the specific question
which was not about circumstances that
made a
broker or gained some contact in the
government but
who was it who decided you would be the
person to contact the government
did you say this to them did they
suggest it to you or something you can't
remember how it came about
i can't remember exactly i expect it
came out of a conversation between
between me and mr greensell about how to
try and
um you know make this government scheme
work better
thank you very you very much thank you
very much mr grant thank you jim thank
you
sebena jenkins uh thank you very much um
this committee is concerned not about
the lobbying inquiry that package will
be doing we're concerned about value for
money
but the revolving door question
is of concern because
it perhaps compromises the value for
money
which people in public office might be
able to
obtain because they're thinking in the
future about
what jobs they might get now you've made
very clear
mr cameron that that wasn't in your mind
at all and i
perfectly accept that but i think what
we have to ask is
um what message do you think
uh your appointment by mr greensville
after you left government and you went
through all the proper procedures and it
was all within the rules
but what message does that send to
officials and even ministers who might
have been dealing with mr greensville at
the time
about their future employment prospects
if they were nice to mr greenfield
greenself from their public office do
you understand the concern that this
raises
i i i do understand um
the concern i think all i would say is
um
you know there there's a appointments
process
i said to the treasury committee about
how we can improve it make it more
mandatory
make it compulsory make it enforceable
maybe change the rules and make them
stronger
but i think that it would be odd if
you you know you couldn't you know
after you leave office you it's
perfectly acceptable to take up some
commercial roles um
there was a gap in terms of this one
there was very little connection between
me and mr green so when
i was in government so it wasn't for me
um a particularly live um
consideration because i thought okay i
mean one announcement about supply chain
finance as prime minister
now i'm going to go and work with this
company it wasn't as if there was some
deep connection no i i i don't think
that's
that's i'm not making that accusation at
all
um but i think we need to ask ourselves
um how appropriate it is
for people who have had dealings with
a particular business while they were in
office
being subsequently employed by that
business
not because then there is definitely
anything bad
to have happened but because of the
relationship
it complicates um in terms of
i think it's it's very difficult this
because it is
you know i'm sure you would agree we do
want an interchange of people coming out
of the private sector and into the
public sector
people going from the public sector into
the private sector and if you off the
top of my head you think of someone
who's
worked in the treasury in the finance
area would that preclude them from
you know when they leave after 10 years
or 20 years or 30 is going to work with
a bank so we have to sort of
i can see the principle of what you're
saying we have to think of the
real world um examples and then this
general question about i mean i'm in
favor of interchange between public and
private sectors and so
you have to be careful that what you do
doesn't make it impossible
i agree with that and we produced a
report while you were in office
from the public administration select
committee which
addressed all this and raised all these
concerns i'm afraid
it wasn't you personally but your
government rejected all our
recommendations and now the chair of
akama is suggesting it should be put
onto statutory footing there should be
a much more formal process because there
is so much more interchange between
business and government and i hope when
you appear in front of pacquack
uh that you will read that report and
the subsequent report that the public
administration constitutional affairs
committee did in
2017 i'd say a rather better report
and that you will consider these issues
before you appear in front of that
committee and i'll leave it there on
that point
i'll bring you back later sir jeffrey
ben sorry not mr jeffrey clifton brown
um mr cameron you attended the uh launch
of the pharmacy early payment scheme in
2012
two years after lex greenhill had come
into number 10
uh at what point did you become involved
with that scheme was it the normal sort
of prime ministerial briefing
just before the launch or had you been
involved at an earlier stage of its
design
i i don't have the paperwork but my
my guess would be that this initiative
was worked up
uh it would have gone into my box and i
would have agreed it and agreed to the
announcement probably at the same time
that would be um what i think would
would happen um and as i say i was
thought it was a good piece of work and
broadly speaking still do
so you were
well briefed on the scheme before you
went to the launch in 2012
there was another four years at least
after you were you were still prime
minister given that you've waxed lyrical
both to the treasury select committee
and this commit committee
on the benefits of the scheme why were
there no other schemes
i i don't know the answer to that well
you're a prime minister
you were prime minister but supply chain
finance was a
a it's a relatively niche area um
in life and for a prime minister it's uh
very niche
um and as i say i was more interested
frankly at that stage in the
private sector commercial part of it
because the pressure in
government if you remember at the time
was you know the economy was beginning
to restart that the banks weren't
lending and so credit there was the
credit crunch and so ideas that could
get
capital into private sector firms so
they could create jobs were at a
premium that's why i was so keen on the
scheme so
but i'm sorry to give an unsatisfactory
answer um i think
it would be better to ask the cabinet
office of the treasury and perhaps mr
greenson himself
what got why did these other schemes get
stuck
were there no other applications which
things did you look at
um and uh i think that is a very
worthwhile question but i don't
personally have the answer i'm afraid it
just said that it was a very niche
idea i'm still slightly curious why lex
greenhill
was given an office in number 10 rather
than somewhere in the treasury or
cabinet office or somewhere what was it
why did he need to come into number 10
if it was such a niche idea i think he
was in the cabinet office not in number
10
um i think that um
uh i think it was the canada office it's
niche but
as i said in the private sector part of
it
if you you know we were spending a lot
of time trying to get
funding for lending trying to get loan
guarantee schemes going trying we have
the
i think it was called the merlin
agreement with the banks which was all
about
trying to get the banks to commit to a
certain amount of small business lending
and here was this idea that seemed to
extend credit
to small businesses in a different way
so that was the bit i was enthusiastic
about
but i'm sorry to give an unsatisfactory
on the other part
thank you mr cameron i wanted to ask
back in 2011 2012 was there a specific
problem with getting payments to
pharmacies
that you were aware of well i think
that there was a problem in that they
got
the payments um quite late
because of the bureaucracy and i think
if you
look at what happened since um i think
it is i mean i
i think it is a success story and the
figures i've seen sorry mr cameron can i
just ask
can i just ask sorry we were were you
aware that pharmacies were getting paid
that a large number of pharmacies were
getting paid late as a result of
bureaucracy
um i don't think it was something i
would previously be aware of but when i
saw
i'd have to be careful here because it
was a long time ago but having examined
what this proposal has done i can see
that it's been
a success and i can give you if you like
examples of pharmacies
who have whacked literally about it so
can i ask
mr cameron sorry to interrupt you again
so would you say that this
scheme was introduced because the
solution existed rather than the problem
existed
i think both and there wouldn't be a
solution if there wasn't a problem
um i mean as i said i think the treasury
secretary there was one
pharmacy told in greece at the time that
annual charges had gone down from 7
000 pounds a year to 400 pounds a year
um
and a lot of you know you know a lot of
extra
cash was given to pharmacies more
quickly so i think it was both a problem
and a solution
so but uh just referring to your earlier
answer when you referred to the
the pharmacy scheme at the at the
beginning of the session
you were saying that uh it costs money
for the treasury to borrow the money
required to make prompt payments
is it not true that through this scheme
you're actually asking these community
pharmacies these small businesses in our
town centres
to bear those costs rather than the
treasury having to bear those costs even
though it must be considerably cheaper
for the treasury to do it
well of course the supply chain finance
works on the basis that
pharmacies get the money up front but at
a
discount so ie they're getting less than
the full amount
they're getting in early so yes they are
paying for it but when you
look at what pharmacies pay for
banking and for credit and for bank
loans and all the rest of it
it's far cheaper and that's why i was a
success
with pharmacists the point i was making
about the treasury was that
um one of the reasons the treasury has
been quite resistant to
even proper payment is as nick would
first explain
to the treasury select committee even
prompt payment does have costs for the
treasury
but the costs for the treasury are
presumably cheaper than the costs for
the pharmacy
the pharmacies of uh the discount that
they had to
they had to take in order to take
advantage of this scheme
yes this is where it gets very
complicated if
in an ideal world the treasury advanced
the money
as the supply chain finance provider
does immediately
to the pharmacy with no delay that would
probably be cheaper all round so we
asked ourselves the question
why doesn't that happen and the answer
is a
bureaucracy and the answer is b the
treasury doesn't like
varying even that cost and that is why
uh this solution is a good workaround
for that problem
and one of the reasons why it's worth
thinking about
is of course a lot of government payment
is not to small businesses like
pharmacies it's to
very big suppliers and i think it's a
good point to make that of course
if the treasury pays the really big
suppliers early
it is incurring cost because it's having
to borrow the money
whereas if a supply chain finance
provider pays the big suppliers
um the big suppliers are effectively
paying a little bit
for the benefit of getting the money
early i hope that makes sense but in
your in your
either way through this sort of thing
it's important to understand those
dynamics in your earlier evidence though
mr cameron you said that this
this scheme was of benefit to small
community pharmacies and now you're
saying that actually it
it it's good because the bigger chains
are having to pay a greater
share of the costs rather than the
treasury can you identify who
who's who's the real beneficiary here
who actually was the real beneficiary of
this uh of this particular scheme
the beneficiaries or the beneficiary of
the nhs pharmacist
was really twofold first is pharmacists
who are small businesses worrying about
cash flow worrying about working capital
they were getting their money minus a
discount up front
which was good for them uh i can give
you the percentage of the number of
pharmacies that took part and i can also
give you
their testimony about why they liked it
so that's beneficiary number one
beneficiary number two was the
government because the government
by the nhs was reimbursing pharmacies in
some cases for their cost of capital
and that was an extra expense and so i
think there was a saving to the
government of 100 million pounds
a year saving to the taxpayer
um can you can you tell me were you
aware of any conflicts of interest
in rolling up this scheme
i wasn't aware of any uh conflicts of
interest my understanding is what
happened but i sort of pieced this
together
from some of the press reports and what
i've had to find out subsequently is
what happened was
lex greenfield came into government
worked on
supply chain finance and this particular
scheme was put in place by
citibank who he had used to work for but
no longer worked for
and the reason for that is i think
citibank were the government's
payment agent what then happens is
mr greenzel leaves government and in a
competitive tender
green sill wins the contract off
citibank to provide the service
i think that was in july 2018 before i
joined
the company so i think in terms of
conflicts i mean you'd have to ask him
but
i think he would argue that he wasn't
conflicted when in government because it
was
run by the government's existing payment
agent
is that what you're getting do you not
think it was slightly
uh useful for him while he was in
government to be able to
implement a scheme that his uh own
company was
was well placed to provide the finance
for at a later date
well i i there was a press article about
this that said
um you know elect greenseal introduced a
scheme
from which he directly benefited and i
thought that was
um not really accurate because of course
his firm
it didn't take over this contract um for
a further
six years and it did so on a competitive
tender i thought it was a bit like
saying
um i benefited from arranging your
marriage
six years ago because six years later i
married your ex partner i mean it seemed
to be that was an unfair
argument
okay i think i understand and
when you first heard about the scheme um
did you did you encourage civil servants
to particularly push it forward
and to to to implement it
well i i think again i i may need the
bourbon inquiry to show me all the
paperwork of what i received and when as
prime minister so
this is sort of educated guesswork i
think what i've
got is a note in my box saying
here is what the team had been working
on supply chain finance
and the two elements of it i described
and i was signing that off and agreed
the announcement at the same time that
is my
guess about what happened i'm hoping
that the bourbon inquiry will be able to
sort of give me access to the papers so
if i've got anything wrong there i can
come back to you okay thank you very
much only uh richard holden
mp over to you uh thank you chair
um uh mr cameron why not just sort out
the bureaucracy
if there was a bureaucratic element
within the nhs you know
surely that would be the most sensible
thing to have done rather than to bring
in a
different system well of course um
in many ways that would be a sensible
suggestion but i think there are as i
said there are two
sort of barriers here one is the barrier
of
bureaucracy which is and it's not just
the pharmacy payment i think if you
talk to businesses that interact with
the nhs they'll tell you that
you know there is quite a lot of
bureaucracy understandably because we're
talking about public money so people are
nervous about signing off invoices too
quickly all the rest of it so
the first point is bureaucracy and the
second point is as nick mcpherson i
thought put it very well in the treasury
evidence of the treasury second
committee um there can be some
resistance in the treasury because
early payment does have a cost to them
and then
add this third element which is of
course in the case of the nhs pharmacies
they weren't just being paid early they
were being paid
before drugs were dispensed on the basis
of
being able to predict by our algorithm
what their
prescription history was so that's
something that
that's a risk that perhaps government
wouldn't want to take so i think for
those three reasons it is worth at least
considering this
just on that point though i mean
obviously early payments would have a
cost
but you know it's a pretty small cost
for the
treasury given the cost of borrowing for
uh
government surely that the bigger cost
would be the fact that
the um pharmacies would have to factor
in the fact that we're going to get less
money
so therefore they charge more or push
for a higher price for their product
in order to rebalance that so the real
so there's actually the real cost is to
the taxpayer at the end of the day
anyway
well i don't i mean i'm not the world's
living expert on this but i don't think
that's correct
for this reason that um if you're
advancing
uh like in small business one of your
biggest concerns is
working capital in cash and of course if
you haven't got a good working capital
solution
then you have to go to the bank and
borrow money and that is going to be
more expensive than the cash
that's the discount that you're getting
from the supply chain finance company
but that is i think one of the key
points to this whole
argument if you're a business there are
various sources of finance to you you
can
sell equity you can raise debt you can
borrow money from the bank or you can
have working capital arrangements that
give you cheap capital
and that i think is is for a small
business that is what is so
powerful but it just it it
you do understand the issue here uh mr
cameron because
obviously the solution that was come up
with rather than just
sorting out the bureaucracy which would
seem to be particularly you could have
targeted it
just at the small community pharmacies
who have exactly these cash flow
issues that the solution you came up
with was via green cell capital
uh a company you then went on to work
for well initially
this was provided by citibank um as i
said
the government
won the contract as i understand in 2018
six years after it was introduced in a
fully competitive tenure because they
were offering to provide the finance at
a
lower cost look i i think that in this
early paying space you should look at
all the options can you get rid of
yourself can you make government
departments pay faster
can you map to change the way the
treasury work to enable
um departments to access treasury style
cost of capital
on their own these are all interesting
arguments but all i'm saying is
if you have something that works and i
think this early page scheme of the
pharmacies has worked
um it is worth thinking about
how to how to keep something like that
going and possibly it's them
and so just one final question but do
you accept that there would also be
potential knock-on costs
to the uh to the taxpayer because
pharmacists would obviously
want to get 100 of the cash and so they
would just
pump up their prices down the line well
the way it worked was that
um as i say there was a benefit to the
taxpayer because instead of the nhs had
to
reimburse pharmacies for that cost of
capital uh the pharmacies were getting
less than a hundred percent of the cash
but getting it up front
so they were benefiting the taxpayer was
benefited at the same time so it was
um without wanting to sound like a
chinese politician a win-win situation
right thank you well can i just um
bring in sir bernard again um in uh
disclosures to the treasury select
committee mr cameron the treasury says
and i quote
that the scheme would allow
participating pharmacies to access
funding earlier than standard government
payment schedule but
after services had been delivered you
said um
in your answers that it would give it
gave money before
services had been delivered can you just
be it seems to be a contradiction there
again i think this is a question for
greeks or capital rather than me but my
understanding is
this scheme was improved from being one
where
pharmacy dispenses drug pharmacy then
immediately gets the money from the
supply chain finance provider that was
phase one
rather than waiting the 30 days for the
nhs to reimburse
it moved to a system where via an
algorithm that predicted the
dispensing behavior of the pharmacy it
gave the money in advance of the drug
being prescribed
why that was able to work is pharmacies
um i think that that's that's that
that's fine that's given
look just explained enough for now we'll
be looking further into this uh
if necessary as a committee so i'm going
to go down to uh sir bernard
jenkin over to you savannah it may be
that this pharmacy scheme was
as you describe it a really positive
benefit to the nhs and to the farmer to
the pharmacy sector and it's unfortunate
therefore that it's become
tainted by what has happened
and the sense that there has been a
failure to manage
conflicts of interest which
undermines public confidence in
imaginative
um and good things um
so i just want to ask about the
influence and transparency and the role
of
and the accountability for crown
representatives which were
an office that was created
under your government uh by francis
maude i think was the
was the champion and i i rather
supported these this world i thought it
was a very good way of
employing much more commercial
accelerating the commercial
capability of the civil service and
improving contracting
um and i was scrutinizing it as chair of
of
pasc at the time but i am now concerned
that they seem to have been outside the
usual
system of public appointments because
public appointments usually covered by
the public appointments
commission so who actually appoints
crown representatives
i'm afraid i'm not a um expert on this i
i like you liked the idea of this
bringing in commercial people to help
government with procurement and
procurement decisions seems to be a
good idea if you remember the context
for this it was
when we came in in 2010 there was a
sense that there was a lot of waste in
government procurement
and that's what these crowd
representatives were there to help with
and i think
by and large it's successful but i i'm
the appointment terms and the terms
office
it's not my area of expertise but i mean
what was the process by which
the policy to have crown representatives
was it was
approved in government were you did it
come together i would go back and
check the paperwork on that um as you
say i think this
was a francis moon initiative but i'd
have to check and see whether i had an
involvement in it um because usually
ministers decide
significant appointments um what's you
suggested that
actually jeremy haywood um unilaterally
brought in um
um uh well i must be careful i mean i
i don't know and i'm sure nigel ball
will get to the bottom of it
i think it was jeremy's initiative
but in terms of how let's green cell's
um you know contract was dealt with and
his reporting lines and all of that i
don't know the answer to that
did he have a contract did he have a
question
i don't recall um
i i i don't recall that so there could
be
there could be so many you know
things coming through your box that you
your crew would have basically
things that have already been sort of
well teed up and and
organized so i mean i think by the niger
morgan inquiry
really helped because he has the full
access to the cabinet papers
and were you at any stage aware of
um officials or crown representatives
being employed
by businesses they were contracting with
or other bit that they were
um double hatting jobs was that we ever
in a way or
anything like that i wasn't aware of
that what would have been your reaction
had you heard about it
well i think the principle um
the sleep asylum representatives for a
second the principle that
if you work in the civil service um
and are paid by the civil service then
you know
there really needs to be a very good
justification for any other commercial
role that's the sort of principle of
course you've got people who are
perhaps on the board of a charity or
have um
you know some other job but it's not a
full-time commercial job the principle
is that that would be
very unusual i mean one study at one
stage
a way of managing interest because
obviously you will have
civil servants who who might you know
own a property they rent out
or have shares in a business or whatever
there's a you have to have a way of
managing
um interest as well as that but i mean
one stage
uh john manzoni looked to say he was
going to hang on to a commercial role
with
uh a private company and in the end i
think he persuaded himself that
it was untenable even though he'd been
given permission to do it
did you give him permission to stay on
the board of sap miller
or would did that come didn't come in
front again i
but you can see that you can see that if
these
arrangements give rise to concern about
conflicts of interest they undermine
confidence public confidence in what the
government's doing however good
the government's work is you can see
that i agree
i think you've got to have a transparent
system for dealing with this
a clear set of rules a clear set of
procedures
and i think that is absolutely right i
mean i go back to my point of view
we've got to try and keep um fluidity
between public and private sectors and
also
i would just make this point today in
all days you know
in a crisis bringing people in
from the private to the public sector to
help
with projects you know i i feel
extremely sorry for some people who came
into government
worked extremely hard to source ppe
or other equipment for the health
service
at a time of national emergency when we
were running out of surgical gowns and
all the rest of it
and are now getting actually all over
the coals i do think we've got to make
sure
you can have some exceptional procedures
for exceptional times
yeah but um what was happening with
crown representatives
between 2010 and 2015 we weren't in a
crisis so
i accept the point you're making
um i'll leave it there thank you very
much uh over to sean bailey mp mr bailey
over to you
uh thank you mr cameron i'm slightly
afraid i might get the same answer but
when it comes to the formulation the
policy around crime representatives can
you recollect what conversations you had
around assurance processes
particularly with regards to individuals
that were taking up those roles what was
the trade-off between
a good news story for value for money
and robust assurance processes on
appointments
i'm really sorry i can't give you a
better answer i just don't recall
i'll have to go away and look and see
what the consultation was at the time
the principle was
let's get good people in to help the
procurement the cap you know
all my experience at camden office was
that the ethics and propriety team
i think ran by sue gray in those days
was very rigorous
but i can't answer your question better
than that i'm very sorry about that okay
i mean we have seen i mean for example
in 2019 alone
we can call out three examples of where
that assurance process is
obviously have to be beefed up so okay
you can't necessarily recollect from
that but
maybe speaking like totally could you
accept perhaps that maybe there were
gaps at the time
that subsequently have had to be filled
on this um
whenever you try to involve
private sector skills in the public
sector and
those people um are maintaining a
private sector role there's always going
to be difficulties i mean i'm a huge fan
of the
non-executive directors who are helping
steer
our departments and give advice to
ministers
and of course they're unpaid but they
are nonetheless working with those
departments and
you know you're always going to get
questions asked about potential
conflicts and all the rest of it i think
it'd be
very sad if we were to lose their
expertise so let's try and find a way of
managing
any potential conflicts rather than what
we don't want is a sort of
berlin wall between public and private
sectors
okay so for you mr cameron where does
that where does that line draw then
in terms of as you say not excluding
that skill set
but ensuring that there's that privacy
there there's that sort of transparency
that's that's available to the public
well transparency is the key
both in if you have a non-executive
director who has business interests
coming in to help a government
department
you need to know what those business
interests are
if you're a civil servant um that
doesn't have a second job but does have
some
business interests or shareholding or
whatever you need to
deal with that i i i think your
inquiry is very important all i would
say is
the time i spend in office you know the
civil service code the special advisors
code the ministerial code the
ministerial declarations all of those
things got
beefed up um and i was comparing
the 2007 ministerial code of the 2010
serial code before going for under the
select committee and yes
it's quite an impressive set of changes
so don't let's
pretend that nothing's been done on this
but obviously there's more
transparency and more good rule making
that can be perhaps put in place
thank you chair and mr cameron can i
just ask as well just with
where does the balance lie between
good strong relationships between crown
representatives and organizations
and preferential treatment because we
have heard in the past there's been this
fear that perhaps
crown reps has for whatever reason
through the relation to the development
developments this preferential sort of
treatment basis so i'm just curious to
understand from your perspective
you know where do you find that balance
i think it's a very difficult question
when we were in opposition looking at
what we were going to try and do in
government to make procurement better
i think one of the things conclusions we
came to is you need to
break up some of these big contracts you
need much more transparency about
government spending and i think we
introduced a rule of everything over 25
000 pounds had to be
declared for new spending and the point
i make is
of course any new system you put in
place with new people with outside
expertise
might have some risks but there was an
existing risk that
those civil servants responsible for
procurement could be captured
in some way by the people they were
procuring from so it's not a
new problem okay
and and finally chair um mr cameron
hindsight being the wonderful thing that
it is would you say perhaps
in the development of this policy it
might have been helpful to be slightly
more over the detail than you were
well i'm sure i was more involved in the
details at the time
but it's now some time ago and
as i said i'll go back and look and see
what i uh did but it is difficult
i wrote my memoirs you go back and you
look at
the big policy areas and what your
information was what your advice was
what your decision was and you can
re-look at it all over again
um i haven't done this one and you know
perhaps this gives me an opportunity to
do that well i think i think mr cameron
when our sister committee
uh the public administration and
constitutional affairs committee sees
you i'm sure they'll give you notice of
some of their areas of questioning and
you may have time
to go back and look at your government
papers which from some of your answers
today may be quite helpful
yeah um so we will we will suggest that
to our sister committee so jeffrey
clifton brown
so talking about detail mr cameron you
were trying to sell a company
that was trying to get a treasury
facility a ccf facility
of 500 million pounds you were trying to
get a sea bills loan guarantee
of 200 million pounds so the taxpayer
was
in hot potentially for a very large
amount of money
i think it's reasonable that the public
should know what precisely you knew
about the company
now you said in answer many answers to
the treasury select committee
you weren't on the audit committee you
weren't on the credit committee
but surely you must have asked some
questions about who the company's
clients were
and what amount of money they were being
lent and therefore you must have had
some fairly good idea
of the finances of the company and
whether it was sound or not
please could you tell us what you do now
of course
i knew about the finances of greenfield
capital
i could see the growth in the business i
could see
the cash flows and the profits and those
things and also when it came to the
customers i was obviously aware of who
our
major customers were and when it comes
to the
ccff really what we were trying to do
particularly as we refine the approach
was to say
those big uk corporates
that wanted to
pay their suppliers early and use supply
chain finance commercial paper to fund
that
would be the beneficiary so it was
companies like for instance
vodafone so i was aware of who the
customers were
and aware of what we were trying to
achieve and i thought it was
a positive idea for getting money into
uk
supply chains with the c bills as i
explained to the treasury committee
i was not involved at all in green seals
process
of getting accredited by the british
business bank
so i was less aware of that policy and
as of course as i wasn't
you know on the credit committee making
credit decisions
um i had a limited involvement in that i
hope that answers your
question well i think the last part of
that answer we know from
uh tom's evidence to us that you were
you told sir tom in fact because we got
the transcript that you had the company
had applied for cc
bill's loan so you were aware of it and
presumably you were lobbying for that
cbc builds
loan or guarantee it was it was a
two-stage process i was not involved
in the accredited in the process by
which green syllabus
that was with the british business bank
i wasn't involved in that i did have a
brief involvement of
when greensell was saying to both the
british business bank and the treasury
that we'd like to be engaged at the
higher level so we can do more to help
those companies requiring credit i was
briefly involved in that just to be
clear
right now i want you to be very precise
in the answer to this question
you told the treasury select committee
earlier that you talked to lex green
hill at least once a week
you've told me just now that you were
more aware of the finances of the
company than you've previously told any
committee
at what point were you aware that lex
greens hills company was in financial
difficulties
precisely at what point in december
2020 there was a telephone call
i recall between myself and mr greenseal
where he reported back that the capital
raised
that was planned which in the summer
early autumn looked like it was going
extremely well
was no longer going well because
of issues of over concentration
on one customer that were of concern to
the
german regulator of greenfield bank and
it was at that moment
that i was told this is not only about
development in terms of the capital
raise but this is
you know potentially going to cause a
lot of difficulties for the company
so that was really the first moment that
i thought there was a
serious threat facing the
company obviously like all companies it
faced um
you answered the question that's the
jeffries are jeffrey yes
so at what point did you realize that
credit
insurance was a problem for the company
i i um i
didn't see that credit insurance was a
problem
in the summer or the autumn um
i wasn't aware of that i think i became
aware of it
much closer to the point when the credit
insurance wasn't
renewed but but given that the company
was only using
one credit insurer bcc during the summer
shouldn't you have been asking questions
about this when
the whole business model relied on
credit insurance
so that those firms that didn't pay up
the company would be
reimbursed by the credit insurance you
should have been asking more precise
questions should you not
well i did ask a lot before i joined the
company as i got to know the company
and saw the importance of insurance i
did ask questions about it
my understanding there was uh and i
think i met with
marsha mclennan the insurance broker
uh my understanding there was some 28
companies involved in
insurance and as i say i wasn't aware
in the summer or autumn of 2020 that
the insurance issue was a looming
problem i became aware of it
later
so you when did you actually
become aware credit insurance was a
problem
well i i don't have a sort of date i can
put on that i'd have to go away and
check my records but
my memory just sort of tried to give you
the
big picture is that you know credit
conditions
eased in the economy even despite of
covid and green city as far as i could
see
from the reports i was getting and the
weekly
podcast i listened into was having a
relatively successful
2021 extended as much threaded in 2001
as
sorry in 2020 as it did in 2019
it was winning new clients um
it was heading for a successful capital
raised
you know it would have been a tricky
year
but this was looking successful and i
don't
remember feeling
a concern about any particular
large problem until that moment in
december
and i think i learned about the credit
insurance problems
later but i i don't want to give a
misleading answer by getting something
wrong you know one's
memory doesn't
will you look into this mr cameron and
will you this is an absolutely key
question in raising capital or anything
else when you knew
that credit insurance was a problem will
you will you look into that
and give this committee a date when you
knew there was a problem
i will i will do my best to do that i
can absolutely
tell you it wasn't it at the time of
march and april 2020 when we were trying
to
um access the ccff i think that's an
important point
thank you thank you sir jeffrey um mr
cameron i've got some quick questions
which will
only hopefully require shorter answers
can you just be clear that you've
been asked by the treasury select
committee to disclose certain
information
have you disclosed all your contacts
relating to your work at green sill
capital
uh with government is everything out
there now is that that's it
i basically answered the treasury well
okay that's so that's exactly my
question you
asked answered what the treasury asked
is there anything more
that you've got that you any other
contacts you had with government
other than what you've disclosed the
treasury so you can go and check but i i
tried to do as thorough a job as i could
with the treasury i think i actually
answered gabe gave them
everything in terms of exposure right
okay because they asked specific
questions i just so
okay so there may be other contacts you
had with government that you haven't
released to the treasury select
committee that's just
just yes or no really um
well i have to go with okay okay i'm not
suggesting
one thing or another i just wanted to
know the answer okay on the issue of
earned
um the uh this is the nhs uh sort of
payday loan without interest scheme
how was it that green sill could afford
to pay nhs staff early
for nothing for no fee because it wasn't
paying early it was drawing down the
money as you earned it
and i please don't attach the web pay
data because it really wasn't it was
you couldn't get an advance on salary
you could draw it down
well that's sorry but but that's before
it's landed in people's pay packets
sometimes before it's landed in their
department in
hospitals counts i was enthusiastic
about this
idea and in terms of how it was going to
be provided free it was going to be a
cost to greens
yes okay exactly right so that's my
point so it was a cost to green sill
and the nhs employs either i never
remember if it's the red army or the nhs
that's the biggest employer in the world
but
it's a pretty big employer in the world
how was it that green silk could afford
to do this
at a cost to green sill and not charge
charge for it because the cost was
relatively low
because of course what green cell and
technology partners do
is operate within the erp
of a company or an organization and pay
their suppliers early so it's relatively
straightforward to switch that into
paying
employees early and of course
you can finance this as an
extraordinarily low cost of
capital because of course the nhs is
going to go on
paying its staff so there's very little
risk to be taken here
so i again okay i mustn't answer for the
company because i was an advisor i'm not
a director i wasn't a director company
but i think they would be able to
explain to you why would be
relatively inexpensive but let's be
clear this was
green seal described it to me as you
know the company's
corporate social responsibility program
in that
this was and we'd had a conversation
about this i remember saying thank you
when you
yeah sorry i'm going on yeah i think i
don't i just i'm
well i mean this is an area we will um
be again looking at more
once the national audit office has been
involved uh further as well
can i um just be clear though in in
terms of your connections with mr bill
crothers
um were you aware that he had taken on a
role with green sill while you were
still prime minister and he was in
office
no i don't believe i were you surprised
did you have any contact with mr
crothers
prior to joining greenfield did he speak
to you about joining greensville capital
as well as mr queen for himself i met mr
i met bill brothers
when i was prime minister he was working
in government but at no stage did i talk
to him about greensville
at that time at that time what about
when just but when you were joining
greenseal did you have any contact with
mr crothers to talk about why
when i left um office and then
joined greenfield in august 2018
um i would have had contact with him
around
but after you joined or before um
i might have to get back to you okay
because mr green said approached you
about joining did mr crothers approach
you about joining at all as well
i don't think he did okay
i don't want to say anything in agronomy
double check that but when did mr
join green cell um in 2015
right um when i would have obviously met
him
if not before shortly after joining but
i'm
to be clear when i was in government
okay
i mean the question really is whether
you mr greens approached joe out joining
i wondered if mr crothers had approached
you about joining green still capital
but you're saying you can't remember
think so but i mean just to be clear
i think that you know when i was prime
minister i didn't know that
mr crothers was no no i'm not certain
yeah okay well you tell you've said that
when i was the greenseer i didn't know
mr brothers had stayed on at the
government right well okay uh we'll
we'll come back to that
i think our sister committee may do
craig mckinley mp brief question please
yes briefly mr cameron um when you were
doing your own due diligence on on this
company
you said to sir jeffrey clifton brown
that you were involved with some of the
you know you're looking at the finances
on a regular basis
did it not seem an odd ball type of
whiz-bang
scheme to be offering uh sort of
financing to nhs employees for free
uh given that they're going to be a vast
number of transactions
banking costs potential for debt
write-offs when people
it can't be recovered and debt recovery
procedures this
i know you said it's social
responsibility but i mean i haven't
looked at this in great detail but to me
it it's sort of too good to be true when
things are
uh described in that way they generally
are
i mean i wouldn't have touched this with
a barge pole personally
um or were they trying to just make
themselves look very big with a
five-star climb so they could
collateralize
a new type of debt to sell to the market
and just make themselves bigger
mr cameron you've got concerns about
that mr cameron
first of all um when i joined greenfield
um
earned wasn't even thought about so i
did due diligence on green sill
before 2018 i joined earned um really
came about um out of a sort of sense
that if you pay suppliers early why not
pay
employees early and as i said greenzoo
was able to do it at a very low cost
because accessing the capital markets
and
accessing companies erps is what they
did
and the sense i had was that mr
greensteal's view was
instead of having some other corporate
social responsibility program giving
money to the royal opera house or what
have you
let's focus our efforts on providing
this to the nhs for free
and if that costs 10 million a year or
such or
whatever um that is our give back to the
uk that was the sense i got about the
social the purpose of
of this obviously um greensville wanted
earn to be a massive success
not just in the private sector but all
over the world it was seen as a
you know because you've got lots of
these payday apps and most of them
they look good but they are charging you
perhaps 50p or one pound every time you
access early a bit of your salary now
that 50p or one pound doesn't sound that
much
but it is actually quite a high apr and
so the beauty of earned was to say we
never charge the employee
you might charge the employer in the
private sector so i thought it was a
very exciting
prospect and but obviously with the
demise of green silk and itself has come
to an end and sold i think to wage
stream
okay but that was the thinking right
well i think it's
certainly an area that's going to be
looked into considerably more siberna
jenkin
thank you very much um we're nearly
finished um
i just want to reflect on what
if we report on this matter um as public
as the public accounts committee
what kind of lessons should we be
drawing from all this what what do you
think you
would you would advise us to make as
recommendations
that we can draw from this
and obviously it's not about lobbying
and we can agree that there should be
better and more transparent management
of conflicts of interest
but in terms of for example the
appointment of crown representatives
um you know in retrospect what would you
recommend about that
i i would be very nervous about making
recommendations to you i think the
the i would almost put it the other way
around and say
look clearly there's always work to be
done
on managing conflicts on transparency
on rules for the jobs people do when
they leave office
on how you manage inflow and outflow
from the civil service to the private
sector of course
that needs to be properly done but but
in what you do
don't lose the ability to access private
sector skills
don't lose dialogue between public and
private sectors and all this issue we've
just been talking about
but it applies i suppose a little bit to
the nhs pharmacy scheme
there is an immense potential for
technology to improve the way
we are paid or the way we live or the
way we work and all the rest i
understand all that but can i be a
yeah okay i think you have to leave room
for innovation yes of course we do um
but um i mean there are echoes of the
carillion
collapse in all this in that um what we
found in that was that the government
was the system the government system and
the government culture was blind
to certain aspects of the risks of
dealing with
a company like carillon it looked at the
accounts but it didn't really understand
the risk in the balance sheet adherence
and balance sheet for example
this business about the reliance on
credit insurance in the
rather complicated financial model
adopted by greensell
how many people do you think in the
government really understood
the extent of the reliance on credit
insurance and what a vulnerability to
the business that that was
well i think the answer i mean i don't
know the direct answer to the question
how many people knew but it
underlines the need for financial
expertise in government absolutely
and financial expertise is some of it is
probably going to have to come from the
private sector
so um you know that
you know i think if you there are quite
a lot of senior civil servants
um in the treasury who've gone out and
done
great work in the private sector and
what they bring back in i think is
immense advantage okay
but if cheryl gillan was here bless her
she would be asking about
how risk was understood and
where risk whether where risk lay
because very often
government has contracted things out
thinking they contract out risk
but they're actually carrying a lot of
risk or indeed importing a lot of risk
that was a lesson of the green silk
collapse
do you think that's possibly one of the
lessons here that there was far more
risk around than we
understood pop possibly
um and that's the job of your committee
to work out
how to put those controls in place while
at the same time not losing
the ability to innovate and do things
in a different way okay can i just make
one
last question um what do you think um
you're personally learning from this and
um
uh i wouldn't blame you if you thought
that actually you
you might carry on learning from this
experience um
okay and and what you know what would
you like to
like like i mean put something on the
record for us
that you'd like to put on the record i
think as i said
um you know there were extraordinary
circumstances
in the economy after the outbreak of
kovid
and you know i believe as a result it
was
right to pick up the phone and make some
points to government because i know what
it's like
sitting on the other side of the fence
but you know as i've said
ex-prime ministers are different there
aren't very many
of us we have to act differently think
differently and
so uh restricting yourself
in these matters to an email or a letter
um when we're not in times of crisis
would be a good approach and that's a
key learning i think obviously you know
the decisions you make when you
leave government of trying to construct
a
life of charitable pro bono work for
causes you care about and
commercial organizations you're going to
work with i did take care i did think
very hard i did consult a lot of
wise and eminent people but great care
has to be taken in these things
as you said to the treasury secretary
thank you so jeffrey giftenbrown very
quick point
yes do you think with hindsight
mr cameron you should have been asking
more questions
earlier on last year and you should have
known the company was in financial
trouble
much earlier than december and if you
had done would you not have
lobbied on the way that you did with the
treasury
well certainly in march and april last
year
i did not believe in any way the company
was in
um serious financial difficulty and i
think i've been backed up by that
by the evidence that's been given by mr
greensell and
um others you know when asked when he
thought the company was in serious
financial difficulty he said
december 2020. um
so i i'm not sure i can be expected to
know better than
the person running the company when it
was in financial difficulty in terms of
questions asked
and this is the point you know people
make
you know there were issues about the gam
fund
issues about the exposure to gupta and
other issues and throughout my time
working for this company before i joined
it i asked all of those questions and
sought
reassurances on a number of those issues
and look as an advisor to a company
who's not
a board director you do look at does
this company have a properly constituted
order does it have a property
constituted legal function does it have
a property constituted risk committee
who's the chairman of them
uh as you said to the treasury selection
financial insurance
does but i think these are important
points so all of those questions i
asked yes okay well thank you um
mr cameron when you were prime minister
and i would go to school assemblies
very often the children would say to me
what's the prime minister like
and i would say something you might be
surprised reasonably positive
because these were 10 and 9 and 10 year
olds what do you think i should say to
those school children now
after your 56 texts to government
and the issues that have risen over the
last few months how would you like to be
just remembered and described
well i hope people will look back at
a record of public service
as an mp as the leader of the opposition
and as a prime minister who put together
the first
kurdish government in 70 years who had
to deal with
very tricky economic situation but with
a government that created i think
more jobs over six years than any
government
before or since and a government that
made
a lot of changes such as equal marriage
that has made our country a better place
now of course this has been a
difficult experience explaining my
involvement with this company and the
decisions i took
but ultimately i made a choice to join a
company that i believed
could be a british success story sadly
that has ended
uh badly i made a choice to talk to the
government about
important changes we thought we could
make that would benefit the country
and actually our system works in the
government considered them
everybody knows about them because of
meetings that were held that were only
reported because of the changes i put in
place as prime minister
and ultimately decided not to go ahead
with them
so um i'm
i hope that gives you some material for
talking to a
school assembly well thank you so do you
regret really the last few months given
what you would like to describe to your
legacy as prime minister
well obviously this has been a difficult
i mean never mind difficult for me i
care much more the fact that it's been
difficult for people who work very hard
for green sill who really believed in
the company
who lost their jobs and had to find
other employment and you know as i said
to the treasury state committee i'd say
to you if you work for a company that
goes into administration
you know it's a very unhappy and
distressing and difficult
experience and you look back at the
choices you made and you think what you
could have done differently
and there'll be lessons to learn and i'm
sure reading your committee's report
reading the treasury's committee report
will
will help everyone concerned with those
lessons well thank you very much and
leave your time and apologies that we
ran slightly longer than we expected
order order
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended the proceeding
has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended